[Musica]
di ciclismo Secondo me c'era molto
bisogno per valorizzare un territorio
che non aveva traffico pesante Le Terre
di Siena erano questo e soprattutto
avevano
le strade bianche avevano ancora un
patrimonio che a quel tempo non era
considerato un valore Anzi la strada
bianca era un disvalore era un parametro
di zona depressa abbiamo ancora la
strada bianca perché il sindaco non è
abbastanza visto a trovare i soldi per
asfaltare questa era la condizione di
Allora dal 97 arriva L'Eroica l'eroe che
è un gadget offerto a gratis a quelli
che vengono a fare la Bartali che so più
o meno amatori pistolati come quelli
avrete visto qualcuno di voi alle strade
bianche con tutto il rispetto Ma insomma
quelli che pensano da amatori di andare
quasi forte come quelli di domani
cittadini al Fiandre e li ribaltammo i
termini all'eroe che si veniva per non
competere per andare sulle strade
bianche riscoprire un certo ciclismo e
premiavamo alla carriera vorrei dire
alla coreografia cioè le bici vecchie
quelli che venivano con le maglie di
lana alla rievocazione di un di uno
sport che si era perso quindi il primo
atto di amore nei confronti di un
territorio magnifico e rischiava di
diventare brutta periferia Perché questo
era il processo che stava succedendo
ovunque
il secondo atto di amore nei confronti
di uno sport formidabile come il
ciclismo il ciclismo guardate in Italia
e in Francia almeno ha scritto la poesia
la prosa la storia del Novecento la
letteratura del 900 tutti i Grandi
scrittori italiani non i giornalisti di
settore hanno scritto di ciclismo hanno
scritto del duello sportivo del secolo
tra Bartali e coppia hanno scritto di
Bottecchia hanno scritto storia un
Romanzo popolare una chanson degest
formidabile sulle gesta di questi eroi
popolari Ricordiamoci e Bartali e coppie
meriterebbero il titolo di padri della
Repubblica perché hanno reso dignità un
paese che era uscito dalla seconda
guerra mondiale tradendo due volte per
entrare e per uscire perché gli italiani
erano questi ci hanno reso dignità a
loro
quindi
L'Eroica era anche un omaggio a uno
sport che unico Guardate io mentre prima
e mi tocca fare cose anche in divenire
ho scritto di Giancarlo antognoni e oggi
è un Finish gli anni no uno sport che
come tale non esiste più io lì non dò
tante speranze oggi esiste una
produzione di spettacolo Oggi esiste
business tutto in funzione ai diritti
televisivi di tutti i mestieranti e se
ne sono appropriati può piacere o meno
ci mancherebbe altro a me ogni tanto mi
piace anche guardarlo ma se c'era uno
sport aveva la possibilità di rimanere
il più vicino possibile alle sue radici
Questo era il ciclismo perché il
ciclismo era bellezza della fatica e
gusto dell'impresa cioè quella roba e
ora mi fanno firmare anche negli eroi a
caffè perché poi l'eroe L'abbiamo
portata in giro per il mondo ci manca un
continente solo che è l'Australia ma
siamo pronti anche l'asse non fosse
stata la pandemia quindi la il secondo
atto di amore era nel tentativo di far
rivivere il rinoceronte vi ricordate
quello che ho detto prima di dire ma
perché lo sport come era non potrebbe
avere un pubblico abbiamo scoperto che
c'era un bisogno di questa roba
incredibile vi do il dato io non so
quanto tempo ho bloccato e mi è perché
tanto si è stato autorizzati a fermarmi
però oggi noi siamo 9.000 a Gaiole in
Chianti a mandarli via perché Gaione
Chianti fa mille abitanti ne fa 2.500 in
un territorio vasto
9.000 ma sono
25.000 in provincia di Siena da tutto il
mondo tra l'eroi tra L'Eroica Montalcino
Buon Convento noverorica la strade
bianche 6.500 e il Tuscany Trail che un
ragazzo in gamba Andrea Borghi si è
inventato da qualche anno a questa parte
e che riproponendo le strade bianche
salvate dalle eroica e io spero salvate
definitivamente perché comunque sia c'è
sempre da stare molto attenti
soprattutto quando arrivano grandi
investitori anche sul nostro territorio
di questo si è trattato a quel tempo La
riproposizione di un territorio era
magnifico di per sé e che si poneva come
meta di destinazione speciale peculiare
per il resto del mondo
25 mila iscritti dal mondo in queste
manifestazioni perché il Tuscany Trail
fa
4.700 e oggi Io dico il dato per ma è
valido per tutte le terre di Siena
Gaiole in Chianti 1998 alla seconda eroi
aveva Zero posti letto alberghieri 0
c'era una foresteria della viticola
Toscana era però soltanto per i soci del
Castello
oggi ne ha 1320 oggi la popolazione è
risalita E comunque siamo un po' sopra
la soglia Vitale senza cantare vittoria
ma ci siamo vivi e verdi ancora resiste
il tavolo del 37 resiste Il Pallaio
resistono e
21-22 associazioni di volontariato che
ci hanno permesso di ospitare un grande
evento mondiale e io sono fierissimo di
aver rappresentato
ora alla comunità europea ospiti d'onore
4 giorni sono tornato l'altra notte
perché evidentemente questi valori hanno
trovato un sacco di gente e gli
aggiudicati cosa buona e giusta gli
aggiudicati politicamente molto corretti
vorrei dire per inciso un passante che
lì ci sono a proposito di imprese posti
impossibili come hanno titolato un
fantasia che io sono stato anche uno sì
che è vero si è inventato
L'Eroica dei professionisti che oggi si
chiama strade bianche e si è inventato
siccome l'hanno citato anche il giro bio
che al sottoscritto lo dico Andrea di
prima Gori Sì forse Gori e che mi è
costato singolarmente un milione e 200
ve lo dico perché non prendete esempio
da me una volta mi hanno mandato alla
business School anche a insegnare a
raccontare queste storie gli ho detto
Fermi tutti però Vi premetto non
prendete da me per fare i soldi perché
io non ne ho fatti fortunatamente
nemmeno ne vorrò fare Ora che me li
offrono da varie parti però Tenete
presente che fare la cosa giusta
inseguire i propri sogni sentire di
militare per un'idea può comportare
anche questo a me ha comportato il non
riconoscimento della paternità di una
corsa nata nel 2007 9 ottobre eroi a
progetto mio per Regione Toscana e che
oggi viene paragonata dal livello
televisivo al valore del Fiandre che
qualcuno ha un passà nello zapping
domani si fermi a guardare che cosa è in
Belgio quel tipo di corsa che è una roba
sacrale Guardatela giusto per vedere i
milioni di persone che stanno là sulle
strade bene la nostra è considerata la
sesta monumento è l'unica è cent'anni
dopo è stata inserita in questo cosa che
è tutto di fine di fine 800 inizio 900
Le altre cinque grandi monumento non mi
interessa un nerd Avete visto a una
volta abbarta gli dissero contentati
dopo che gli avevano fregato il Tour del
'49 sia più bisogno di Quattrini che di
Gloria io non ho bisogno nemmeno di
Quattrini la gloria me ne frego
altamente tutti quelli che mi vogliono
bene me la riconoscono Quindi comunque a
Siena c'è una grande corsa mondiale oggi
nella città e nel territorio che
Francesco Moser avrebbe a dire Ma tutto
questo ciclismo a Siena Ma quando mai
c'era io ho fatto due anni da dilettante
in Toscana e non avevo mai vinto una
corsa in provincia di Siena Ma perché le
corse a Siena non c'erano bene Oggi c'è
una grande corsa mondiale 25 mila
iscritti da tutto il mondo a queste
manifestazioni
ci sono 100 bambini l'unica città in
assoluta contro tendenza che fanno
ciclismo agonistico a Siena il pedale
Senese ha un fiorire di bambini e di
genitori che portano i loro bambini a
fare ciclismo io però ho fatto anche il
giro bio e quello che l'ho pagato
Gino significava altro progetto per
Regione Toscana però fare la cosa giusta
Si può pagare la cosa giusta Io l'ho
pagato un milione e due mezzo i mezzi ce
li avevo per altri mezzi mi hanno
costretto a metterceli facendo conto che
mi avrebbero impiccato economicamente
all'albero più alto a me importava una
beneamata niente importante Ho pagato
Sono stato costretto a rendere
imprenditoria i miei sogni il marchio
eroica a portarlo in tutto il mondo a
aprire gli eroica caffè Certo un
imprenditore dietro io non so leggere
nemmeno l'estratto conto però l'idea di
fare del ciclismo pulito io l'ho pagata
perché si poteva si poteva fare il
problema è che quando Levi agli
apprendisti stregoni a tutti gli addetti
ai lavori autoreferenziati la materia
prima rischi di pagarla forte bene Io
oggi sono orgoglioso di potervi dire che
l'ho fatto l'ho pagato ma lo rifarei
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]